my dad we have a photo of it i was doing
huckleberry finn
right i played huckleberry right right
so you know when an asian guy or korean
dude's playing huckleberry friend
you get an applause break when you hit
the stage
because you don't expect it so when you
they see an asian guy with a little you
know maid
and the overwatch and doing this right
right oscar already people are like
crying laughing right but then my mom
took a photo of my dad my dad is in the
third row
i have it on my instagram bro oh [ __ ]
dead asleep [ __ ] awesome
yeah and you know they don't realize
that they're [ __ ] you up
you know it would it would be great
almost like pop-up video
like if you're a kid and your parents
[ __ ] with you or leave you
alone or my grandmother would i be doing
my homework and she'd come in and turn
the she wouldn't even look at you just
turn the [ __ ] light off in me
yeah yeah i'm sitting in the dark yeah
and i'd go i'm in here doing my homework
should turn the [ __ ] line and go
so sorry so during that day when that
light's free you don't
[ __ ] do a [ __ ] thing but at night
you you [ __ ] want to learn at night
but not during the day when you don't
need a [ __ ] lamp to do your homework
yeah yeah
you wish a video with a little bubble
would pop and go
let this one go because this will [ __ ]
with you for the rest of your life
and then you read the bubble you're like
okay i got it it goes away
because they [ __ ] put this [ __ ] on
you that affects your relationships it
affects your [ __ ]
uh uh um intimacy it affects your
friendships and the
awful man what my parents used to do uh
my mom or
all like all my aunties do my teeth they
used to put all the kids
under age of 10. for every single
birthday party they don't
they gave us boxing gloves and the kids
would just box it out like we were
bloodied up
and then the adults are [ __ ]
serious yeah i grew up in the
philippines and the adults would um
bet on which kid would win human [ __ ]
fights
you know what that's [ __ ] all human
[ __ ] fights [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah
i love it i mean it's awful
that's awful got it another thing they
would do is they would put this like
they would
put this big thick thing of a bamboo log
and then they would put lube or slime on
it
and then whichever kid would like fall
off of it first so
we were just like hanging on like this
loop
it was just it was a physical torture
tactic like their
agony was their entertainment your
childhood was like ninja warrior then
there was
a terrible [ __ ] very cool running
through the fire of the yard the side of
the house
no but but you don't but nobody put a
[ __ ] premium on kids like now
yeah yeah i mean you know it was fun for
them
they're probably [ __ ] drinking
[ __ ] laughing hard
yeah but you think it's easier let me
ask you that do you think because we
grew up
because you're what 60 you said i'm 50.
right so when we were kids [ __ ] 21.
[Laughter]
so has that new car smell that before
if he was a car you took it here you go
we'll take it
yes
we grew up in the day where like racism
was like outward
yeah like kids would walk up and do this
in front of me and just nothing would
happen
and people like the teachers would
high-five the kids and then the
teacher would do it you know they didn't
give a [ __ ] right but now kids right
like it's bobby's birthday they put the
tape right here
happy birthday i'll have a [ __ ] tape
[Music]
but now you know because of you know
it's a cancer culture